verde alternativa o limpia son varios
los adjetivos para hablar de la energía
renovable el último informe de la
agencia internacional de la energía
asegura que este recurso tuvo una
expansión en 2021 de un 3% respecto a
2020 con 290 gigavatios de nueva
capacidad instalada lo que supone un
récord la nueva economía global de la
energía está al alza sin embargo los
retos son grandes
para mí el punto ciego del debate
climático es el financiamiento de
energías limpias en países emergentes
cuando miramos nuestras cifras más del
80% de las emisiones en los próximos 20
años provendrán de países emergentes
además menos del 20 por ciento de las
inversiones de energías limpias se
destinan a estos países
según la agencia durante los próximos
cinco años será china el país que
encabezará la capacidad instalada de
energías renovables con el 43% del
crecimiento global seguida por europa a
eeuu e india si bien el futuro de las
energías verdes es aplaude por muchos
los gobiernos deben esforzarse más para
cumplir con las metas adoptadas en la
cob 26 entre ellas la limitación del
calentamiento global a 1,5 grados
centígrados y la neutralidad de carbono
para 2050 aunque no logremos llegar a
1,5 grados si alcanzamos 16 ó 17 grados
sigue estando bien siempre es mejor que
tener un aumento de temperatura de casi
3 grados para alcanzar esto birol
asegura que habrá que doblar las
capacidades instaladas de energía
renovable entre 2021 y 2026 y además la
demanda mundial de biocombustibles y de
calefacción procedente de fuentes
limpias tendría que crecer hasta 4 veces
más que lo dicho en el informe